où
malheureusement on n'a pas pu faire ce
travail d'idées lors de notre précédent
quinquennat d'opposition même lorsque
nous étions au pouvoir et qui est donc
nécessaire de pouvoir inviter des
personnes qui ne pensent pas forcément
comme nous qui n'ont pas forcément les
mêmes idées pour pouvoir échanger s'en
inspire et peut-être faire évoluer notre
pensée et devenir à nouveau la pièce
centrale de l'échiquier politique pour
que les autres partis se positionnent
par rapport à nous et non pas que nous
nous positionnons par rapport à redonner
toute sa place aux militants lui
permettre d'avoir la parole lui
permettent de s'exprimer
le rappelait justement ce qui nous ce
qui nous ce qui nous rassemble
notre vision et puis et puis reposer les
bases d'un fonctionnement de notre parti
qui nous permettra de gagner les
échéances futures
les ateliers de la refondation ça va
nous permettre de se reconnecter avec la
société si ça va nous permettre de
refaire du fonds est de gagner la
bataille intellectuelle
il faut saluer les ateliers d'art
fondations il faut s'y impliquer et on
compte sur vous
[Musique]